whoo all right so just a couple of days
ago Samsung had their unpacked event in
San Francisco and they released some
brand new smartphones first all we get
super excited about if you haven't
already heard let's talk about it
what's going on guys my name is David
Thomas from welcome back to the channel
today we're talking about the Samsung
unpacked event and the brand new Galaxy
Zed flip and the S 20 series that's been
just announce if you watch the unpacked
event like millions and millions of
people did you know that they didn't
give us all the information about these
phones that's why you probably clicked
on this video here to find out
everything you can and if you can't
already tell my excitements just that
little bit higher than usual because
I've just pre-ordered my very own
samsung galaxy s 20 ultra in cosmic
black if you're interested in knowing a
little bit more about the unboxing
experience and the device itself
subscribe to this channel with the
buttons just down below when we'll talk
about it when the device arrives I'll
also most likely be doing a giveaway for
the samsung galaxy s 20 ultra if people
is interested again and subscribe down
below and when it arrives I'll make some
decisions
worst case scenario I'll probably be
giving away the Samsung Galaxy buds plus
because I already have my very own
galaxy buds so I don't need both of them
and I might as well give it to one of
you guys so let's talk about this
unpacked event and focus on the galaxy s
20 most people are expected to get their
shipments on the 6th of March for
America Australia and a couple other
countries most other countries may be
delayed up to the 14th of March so
depending on where you are will depend
when you get your smartphone if you've
pre-ordered one today something that
really fascinated me about this unpacked
event was the announcement all the
collaborations that Samsung's doing with
some giant companies along the way so if
you haven't noticed already samsung has
partnered up with Microsoft Google Xbox
YouTube Netflix and Spotify so at the
end of the day they're giving you a
whole bunch of extra premium features
that are directly built into the UI and
the user experience of the brand-new s20
range just for samsung so it doesn't
matter if you're with Apple and you're
using Spotify or YouTube you're not
going to have some of these key
inaugural features built directly into
your device this is pretty cool because
most people that I know at least use all
of these services pretty much day in and
day out so let's start with the Samsung
cs20 the most basic phone of the range
it comes in two models in Australia the
4G and the 5g the 4G model does not come
out in every single country
I know India is one of the countries
that will get 4G and 5g models of all
three devices the s 20s twenty plus and
the s 20 ultra but Australia
unfortunately does not get 4G on
anything else except the introduction
samsung s 20 the s 20 comes with 563
pixel per inch six point to 120 Hertz
refresh screen rate this is definitely a
good introduction screen size for an S
20 model if you've been previously a
note 10 user you know that sometimes for
small devices a little bit easier to use
but smaller doesn't mean limited this
device comes in three unique colors it
comes in cosmic grey cloud blue and
cloud pink these kind of I guess pale
pastel colors kind of give more of a
kid-friendly vibe to me personally I
don't know what really says to the
market outside of Australia but I know
most professionals or most I guess
adults in a sense won't really be going
out and buying a pale blue or pink foam
most people do want white black gray so
it'll be very interesting to see how
those sales stack up in Australia to the
rest of the world in the demographics
that they are targeting themselves the
s20 itself has some amazing features it
comes with a 64 megapixel with telephoto
camera 12 megapixel one and 12 megapixel
ultra wide as well as a 10 megapixel
front-facing camera so the interesting
thing here to note is the fact that the
64 megapixel main camera is actually
their telephoto camera you don't get the
standard wide-angle lens for the most
powerful most megapixel camera and
sensor which is a little bit strange but
I guess that's why they brought out the
Samsung ultra to kind of push you up the
line for that photography videography
package some of the basics that come on
all of these s20 devices and I won't
repeat them because that's just a waste
of my time and your time as well guys
they come with a minimum of 30 times
space soon
8k video recording across all devices
and thirty-three megapixel snaps from
the video if you want to take a steal
this is actually pretty cool because if
you've gone ahead and recorded an 8k
video and go ah that makes a really sick
photo you can bring that out it's
probably just gonna be a really high
high quality JPEG but you won't be able
to manipulate it as much as a raw you'll
still be able to do quite a lot with
this image that you've extracted
directly from video usually if you've
ever tried it before they are some
potato level photos so it's gonna be
very interesting to see what an 8k video
snapshot can bring to the table now in
2020 as well as a K video recording in
Australia it does not unfortunately come
with a Snapdragon a cease-fire chip
instead it comes with the octa-core 919
chipset this is a bit strange I guess
because America has been brought up with
the not eight six five a Snapdragon chip
so it's kind of yeah little bit unfair
unfortunately but it is what it is it's
still a great chipset from Samsung and
they know what they're doing with the
end of the day so I'm actually not too
mad about this one as usual you'll get
the ultrasonic fingerprint sensor on the
screen itself so under the glass
fingerprint technology 1.5 meter water
resistant up to 30 minutes the thing
here is I guess with all IP ratings is
it's tested in fresh water it is not
recommended whatsoever in pools or in
any beachside location so if you're
gonna go out to the beach underwater for
30 minutes you're probably gonna ruin
your phone if you're gonna take a couple
of snaps really quickly maybe 5-10
minutes you might be right but again and
still highly recommend going out and
drying your phone once you used it
underwater all three devices have fast
charge capabilities but unfortunately
they come with 25 watt charges in the
box even the samsung s 20 volt row so
even though you're paying that $19.99
Australian price tag you still get
charged with a little 25 little what
adapter instead of being bumped up to
the 45 watt the 4g s 20 starts in
Australia at 13 49 or 900 USD the 5g
model
bumps it up a little bit to $14.99
Australian or $9.99 USD as I'm sure many
of you already know because I'm pretty
certain you've all pre-ordered it and
you're watching this out of excitement
let's talk about s 20-plus now the 5g
only version in Australia the thing that
interested me most about this device
itself was it was one of the predominant
devices used throughout the Samsung S 20
unpacked live event if you took notice
of what they showcase throughout that
Samsung unpacked event you'd see that
they really showcased that s 20 plus
more and Samsung S 20 old truck concerns
me personally a little bit because i
pre-ordered the old truck but I'm hoping
that there was reasons for justifying
that in itself I'm assuming that the
fact that the main camera or the main
telephoto camera I guess in the S 20
plus is 64 megapixels and they would
have been using the telephoto for those
sorts of situations maybe it produced a
better image or a better live stream
however I don't really know but it's
definitely something that piqued my
interest
during that live stream if you know the
answer to that one let me know down in
the comments below because I'd be super
interested to find out unfortunately
nothing really changes here between the
s 20 and the s 20 plus you get a little
bit of a bump up in the battery specs
500 extra milliamp hours of battery and
a depth sensing camera on the rear side
so a couple little bonus extras here
nothing too significant for these small
little changes if you want the 128
gigabyte model s 20 plus model in
Australia it's gonna cost you
sixteen hundred and forty nine
Australian or 1099 USD for the 512
gigabyte model it's gonna cost you
eighteen hundred and ninety million
dollars in Australia or $12.99 in
America that's that's pretty steep and
pretty much entering s twenty ultra
range so considering they both have
microSD capabilities you can just go
with a 128 gigabyte model slot a micro
SD card in there and store everything on
the SD card instead of backing it up to
the phone which makes it significantly
cheaper that would be my personal
recommendation if you're looking at
compare
the 128 to the 512 unless you really
really know and understand that you're
gonna use 512 gigabytes of phone
dedicated storage okay let's move on to
the s20 ultra and the reason I'm making
this video the s20 ultra is meant to be
a funnel move device I don't know I'm
ready for the unboxing video I'm sure
you guys are too so basically the specs
itself make this phone stand out so much
to somebody like me from a photography
and videography point of view it really
sets it apart from anything on the
market we're talking a hundred and eight
megapixel main wide-angle camera
so unlike the s 20 and the X 20 plus it
isn't the telephoto it is the main
camera that we're all used to 64
megapixels a 48 megapixel telephoto
replaces that 64 megapixel telephoto
from the X 20 X 20 plus but a bumps up
to a hundred times optical zoom
well hybrid of digital and optical one
of the things here unfortunately if
you've seen any reviews and if you've
seen any of the photos that have come
out from people who have been fortunate
enough to get their hands on during a
live event or got them pre-release some
of these hundred times in photos kind of
look a little bit potato quality from
being honest but the 30 times optical
space zoom it looks decent enough to use
so from a professional point of view I
guess you probably only use the hundred
times oome on sorta lice maybe is a
gimmick maybe something more you're
definitely going to need a tripod
because everybody showcases with a
tripod to get a super steady shot and to
actually capture the image properly but
I guess that's pretty normal even if
you're using a DSLR have a really long
zoom lens it's pretty shaky so zooming
in that far definitely definitely need a
tripod and something to be aware of if
you're planning on using the hundred x
oom as part of your day-to-day routine
finally it comes with a 12 megapixel
ultra wide camera so this is basically
how wide you're going to get it if not a
little bit more i'ma just zoom back in a
little bit
they haven't sumed in too much but now
you're gonna really understand what an
ultra-wide lens gives you with 12
megapixels it isn't as powerful and as
good as the hundred and eight megapixel
but it's supposedly meant to be
fantastic in low-light so with all these
combinations the front-facing camera is
bound to be better right yes excellent
they've bumped it up to 40 megapixels
for some ultra crisp selfies and videos
if this is something that interests you
it's definitely worth having a look at I
think the 40 megapixels on the front
side is nearly unprecedented in the
mobile phone industry if you're a camera
and tech nerd like myself then you're
probably pretty aware that a one inch
sensor is good quality for photography
and not so much videography but we'll
stick with the photography side and if
you know anything about our phones you
know those sensors are like tiny there's
basically nothing in a phone sensor
however not in the Samsung s20 ultras
been released it comes in with a one
point one three three inch sensor which
is basically 40% less than a one inch
sensor but three times the size of an
average phone sensor that's a huge leap
forward if I'm being honest usually we
get little incremental bumps of tiny
tiny tiny tiny until we get to one inch
but this time around we've pretty much
jumped from nothing to something that's
quite substantial and will hopefully
produce some incredible images the
downside of the s20 ultra is the price
if you like me who has already looked at
the price clearly it costs 1999
Australian dollars for the 128 gigabyte
model this roughly equates to thirteen
hundred and forty-nine USD or if you
want to step up to the 512 gigabyte
model well it's gonna cost you just that
little bit more again the 512 gigabyte
model in Australia costs two thousand
two hundred and forty nine dollars which
is equivalent to about 1499 USD
one thing that I can say with great
confidence is if you are a student in
Australia there is some great benefits
for you right now if you jump on the
Samsung educational store and sign in
with a valid student email address you
can save yourself
$400 off the s20 ultra that is a huge
discount especially considering it was
just released just brought out and it
will probably stay at the two thousand
dollar retail mark for the next six to
twelve months until we get a pretty
massive sale like Black Friday at the
end of the year so that's all i hope you
guys today thank you so much for
watching if you're excited to see in the
unbox the samsung s 20 ultra give it
some real good tests throughout the
field that's all I have for you guys
today that's all I have to you guys
today thank you so much for watching if
you're excited to see me unbox the s20
ultra as you can clearly tell I am stay
tuned smash that subscribe button leave
a comment down below what features you
want to see what you want to know about
this device and I'll make sure I make it
happen for you but until then as always
I'll see you next Monday